[Music]
hello my name is mad y garcía I am a
technical account manager at google
cloud and I am going to tell you how to
manage resources and access to them
within the google cloud platform to
understand how to give access to the
google cloud platform is 50  it is important
to first understand how
all the google cloud
platform resources are structured belong to a single project
in the console in a project we can,
for example, monitor the
activated resources and the quota they
consume enable services and apis to
which they are going to give  access to those resources
manage billing and add or
remove collaborators each project is
a separate compartment and each resource
belongs to only one of those
compartments projects can
have different owners and users
are billed separately and are
managed separately to be able to
interact with them there  projects can be
done visually from the console
console 'punt  o cloud dot google.com o
programmatically using
cloud research manager apis
google cloud platform offers
project containers like
organizations and folders that give you
the ability to group and
hierarchically organize resources this
hierarchical organization allows you to
easily manage common aspects
of resources such as  access control
or configuration the
organization is the root node of the
google cloud platform resource hierarchy
is assigned a single
cloud identity directory that
contains users and user groups
if you already have a domain the jesuit
gcp projects  they will
automatically belong to your
organization node otherwise you can
use the google cloud identity
to create an organization
allows you to assign controls to a
collection of projects such as
defining access policies or delegating
responsibility for critical components such
as networking or
billing  folders are nodes in
the organization hierarchy a folder can
contain projects nested folders
up to four levels deep or
a combination of both folders
are optional they are created under the
organization resource and can be used to for
example granularize permission inheritance
on access to resources or
to adjust the inheritance
of organization policies to other
folders or projects
you can create a folder for different
departments or for different environments
then you can set
access policies at the folder level to
segment permissions between  different
project groups
you can also nest folders within other
folders to further separate your
projects resources inherit the policies of their
parent resource each policy contains a
set of permissions and members with those
permissions assigned for example if you
set a policy at the
organization level everyone  your projects
inherit it automatically  Attically and this inheritance
is transitive which means that
all resources in those projects inherit
that policy also something important to
remember when designing
policies policies implemented
higher in the hierarchy cannot
remove access that is granted
to a  lower level for example
suppose a policy applied in
the def project gives the user
mariah the right to modify a
cloud storage package but an
organization level policy says
that maria can only see the
storage packages in the  cloud don't change them
the most generous policy is the one that takes
effect therefore maria could
modify that baguette
the structure of the organization can
be as complex as you consider here
here you can see an example of an
organization with a hierarchy geared
towards giving more granular access to  resources
on the one hand you have more control over the
assignment of permissions but on the other  o
management of groups and associated roles is complicated
when we work with the resources of a
project we have to take quotas into account
google cloud platform imposes
quotas on the use of resources in
projects in such a way that
a strict limit is established on how much  of a
resource your project can use a
quota-controlled value can be for
example the number of requests to a
service per day amount of data
exported per minute or number of
resources raised in the project
quotas protect against
cost overruns and can be
incorrect code indicators
also help to isolate you from other
misbehaving fp clients
so now you know start using
google cloud for free at cloud dot
google.com barra free and start
organizing your resources